i i watched the new wonder woman movie
yesterday
only because i heard it was bad
it was
horrible the new wonder woman movie
may have been one of the worst movies
i've seen
and i'm well let me be clear we watch a
lot of bad luck movies so
but my point is one of the worst big
budget movies i've seen
it was
terrible and i like the first one
but i mean two and a half hours
of unadulterated
[ __ ] [ __ ] it may be worse than
the justice league movie
it may be worse than batman versus
superman
it's all over the place
it's a [ __ ] all over the place
anybody that says to you
that it was a good movie is lying to you
it is one of the lowest rated dc movies
on imdb
right now it is but um
here look this is this let me show you
what rotten tomatoes is doing now
so when you go to rotten tomatoes
let me show you their little [ __ ]
game let me show you their little oh my
god enable us to roll into me oh my god
so [ __ ]
on top of all that i have to enable ads
on ron tomato fine whatever i don't care
um so check this out
so you're going to run tomatoes tomato
meters
critics 63 say so it's fresh 63 say they
like it 72 percent say
audience says they like it now you
wonder you think to yourself you go
how can it be rated solo on imdb
but now the audience scoring rotten
tomatoes is 72 percent i was thinking
that too
i was like that's [ __ ] odd that
doesn't make sense then i realized
something ron tomatoes is doing
something with the audience score
it's called verified audience score now
if you switch from verified audience
score to all audience
it's at 43 there is a 30
difference between verified audience and
all audience
look at the difference and now i'm
wondering what does verified audience
score mean
well verified audience
is something that ron tomatoes put in
place after the captain marvel movie
was put in place last year after the cat
captain marvel all the male trolls were
putting that movie down it wasn't
because the movie was terrible and
[ __ ] sucked it was one of the worst
things i've ever seen in my life
but no no it was because of uh
it was because of trolls um so verified
audience and i looked into this
so verified audience what it means is
you have to prove that you have a
ticket to the movie so you have to
become a verified audience scorer you
have to take a picture of the ticket
send it in and then of that movie then
you're a verified audience for that
movie and then your score counts towards
the verifieds where the verified score
is the one they show
you have to go in deep to find the all
audience squirrel you have to click it
and then dude you have to go three
clicks in to find the all audience score
the one that ron tomato shows is
verified audience you have to show oh
it's because they're saying oh people
don't watch the movie or rating it
here's the problem couple oh and if you
buy the movie with the fandango app
which is owned by which
ron owns raw tomatoes fandango raw
tomatoes the same company
uh after you watch the movie with
fandango it's it it
prompts you to rate it on rotten
tomatoes and it counts as a verified
audience
now i found a little flaw in this system
a wonder woman's a perfect example
wonder woman
didn't just come out in theaters no it
didn't
remember something wonder woman came out
on hbo max
so there's a lot of people that watch
this movie that don't have a ticket stub
that just watch the movie on hbo max i
would gather
the majority of people that watch this
movie
didn't watch it in a theater
didn't watch it in the theater so again
rotten tomatoes is trying to [ __ ]
the curb trolls the reality is the
movie's [ __ ] terrible the reality is
if i was the real score should probably
be 4
4 43 probably lower i think it's worse
than 43
positive but whatever so
the system is already [ __ ] up with
this
because the whole like oh if you have a
ticket it can't
it doesn't matter all right so um
anyway the movie is
really bad and again every time
you criticize a female superhero movie
right
every time you criticize a female super
movie here or anytime you criticize a
freaking female superhero movie
anytime you criticize a female movie
they say it's because you just [ __ ]
hate women oh you i
but again not true this movie
i like the first wonder woman movie i
gave a good review when i review i liked
it i thought it was a good movie
this movie is
all over the place
you could tell there were reshoots it's
guys i'm saying mind you
two and a half
hours long
the verified audience trick gets rotten
tomatoes a nice little bonus from
production companies every time a bad
movie comes out
yep um
think of it this way if ron tomate if
fandango
owns rotten tomatoes which fandango is
that service you could buy tickets
online it would behoove them that the
movies would be rated higher so more
people would go into the app
and buy tickets for the movie i mean
think about it
you if movies are rated people are going
to go watch the movies
so again rotten tomatoes have been
compromised for a while it used to
actually be pretty good in terms of
many years ago it's been compromised for
a while but rotten tomatoes is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
again the all audience scores 43 and
they want to say that it's uh
it's full controls it's all it's every
time every time a [ __ ] female movie
flops it's trolls
so i think patty jenkins
is that that's the female director that
did the first one
she also did the second one and i
thought to my i was really wondering
i was like how is it that
the first one was a good movie and it
was
and the second one was so bad and it's
the same person that did it you know
for example
if you look at the christopher nolan
batman movies they're all pretty good
some people have their favorite ones of
course but you could
in my opinion of course everyone has
different ones but in my opinion if you
look at all three of the christopher
nolan batman movies you're like
wow all of these movies are good
everyone has a favorite one
i understand but the quality and all the
movies are good i'm like man these are
good movies i like them
for superhero movies not a [ __ ]
citizen kane or anything but
uh which again overrated but i digress
i realized something the first movie was
written by three men
zack snyder being one of them and two
other people this movie was just written
by her
by patty jenkins so she got all this
praise for the wonder woman movie
and she figured i got this i
[ __ ] got it
i [ __ ] got this movie and i'm gonna
tell you this
you don't have to believe me
if you have two and a half hour two and
a half hours to waste
becau i'm gonna give you a quick rundown
of a couple things that you should
expect for that i want you to to
understand from this movie okay
you're supposed to believe that kristen
wig is hot
all right um
pedro pascal who i think is great is
playing max
lord um
and you could tell that a half of his
character was just trying to
take shots at orange man bad take making
fun of trump you could tell because
they can't understand something they
can't help themselves
they [ __ ] cannot help themselves
uh and then pedro pascal's accents all
over the place because you know
half of the movie is doing a hispanic
accent but the other half of the movie
he's just doing a
straight-up american accent and i i
can't i ca
it's just again all over the place
they shoehorn chris pine in there and
i'm gonna say this and
by the way you don't have to believe me
so i'm to say a couple things here
that might be spoilers so look if you
really really love want to see this
movie and you love it
hey man i understand go away for 10
minutes
because i'm going to talk about it
because i need to talk about it
okay so just letting you know i can't
imagine anybody watching gives a [ __ ] if
this is spoiled
i i just can't imagine that it matters
to you but whatever
and i'm not making this up people are
gonna think that i'm being a dick or
i'm just trying to [ __ ] be funny this
next statement i'm saying i'm not making
it up
wonder woman literally
somebody in the movie
wonder woman
somebody in the movie
it's not a lie if a man
if a man
did what wonder woman did
there would be me too articles and
variety articles and you would not hear
the end of it
i'll explain you don't see her having
sex so
so don't even get excited for that
in the first movie
chris pine which is named steve i think
chris pine's character dies
right because you know whatever's world
war one now apparently
wonder woman doesn't age so now we're in
1984. okay
the movie has this like wishing stone
which
again makes no sense
for the the one the thing i'm surprised
about this movie is
for a movie that was two and a half
hours long
it two and a half hours long they did
a terrible job a
terrible job of explaining
anything in the movie i don't know how
you could make a two and a half hour
movie
and not explain anything that's going on
in it
like i didn't understand what was
happening
i i again it's a comic book movie this
is
this isn't highbrow [ __ ] folks this is
pretty simple
it should be pretty simple stuff explain
so anyway this is wishing stone
steve chris pine the character from the
first movie he's dead right
fine whatever
she wishes that he were to come back
like she wants you want that's her
that's her wish she wants him back
that's her love she loves this guy
chris pine's character she loves him she
wants him to come back fine
her wish is granted
she comes back he comes back excuse me
but he doesn't like just up here and
come back right
so she has his wishing stone right
wonder woman has his wishing stone
she wishes for chris pine's character
who died in the first one to come back
because she loves him
fine his brain goes
into the consciousness of a another
person of some john smith who's living
in the 80s
now everybody else when they look at
john smith they see john smith but not
her when she looks at him she sees chris
pine
okay fine they even point out the fact
that chris pine knows he's in somebody
else's body he's isn't he's
he's in his apartment they make all
these jokes about it
whatever he's in his apartment they make
all these jokes about it fine
now
they have sex
you could tell because the next morning
they're in bed together and they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] they literally [ __ ] okay
they [ __ ] in the movie now
the guy that chris pine took over
john smith didn't have any consent
didn't have any say in it at all she
just
[ __ ] him he did not consent to having
sex with her
he did not give his okay and i know i
understand
it's gal gadot who would say no i agree
with you
i wouldn't complain but i'm just
pointing out
that if this movie was a dude and wanted
to br
if this was captain america and he
wanted to bring up
[ __ ] whatever her [ __ ] name is
back and she inhabited somebody else's
body
right
and she [ __ ] him this would be
a humongous deal now mind you i'm not
offended
obviously it's a movie i don't care you
know i don't care you know i could give
a flying
[ __ ] about it i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
about it
but i'm just pointing out the double
standard i'm pointing out can you
imagine if this was the other way around
so all i'm saying is is that
in this movie using the metoo movement
and the women and the time's up and
using their terminology
she the dude
she
dude now let's point that out there now
so something else i want to point out
okay something else i want to point out
um
the kristen wiggs the story line in the
movie again if you want to watch it you
could skip if you want fine but you're
going to hate it anyway
uh
kristen wiig's is and character s and i
[ __ ] you not and i [ __ ] you
not is michelle pfeiffer's
character from batman returns i mean
paint by [ __ ]
numbers okay
she's a nerdy she's your dude it's it
had
every cliche you could think of
she's a nerdy girl you know
like you know that so for we're to
believe
that that kristen wiig and
wonder woman kristen wiig and wonder
woman
are uh i like some sort of
archaeologist or something or some sort
of historical
scientist i mean what something to that
effect right
something of that effect
and kristen wakes character
is this nerdy is like oh the i'm this
nerdy cat look at me i'm a [ __ ] nerd
oh man and she just wants to be like gal
gadot's character you know oh look at
that oh i'm so nerdy oh
so when she touches the wishing stone
again
[ __ ]
terrible she touches the
the stone or whatever
she becomes hot that's right
then she becomes hot kristen wiig
and guess what she doesn't need her
glasses anymore
just like michelle pfeiffer just like
[ __ ] peter parker
the whole like i guess i don't need
these glasses anymore
and now i'm hot and now i'm hot kristen
wing
i think her name's barbara in the movie
look how hot i am oh yeah and she could
she can't walk in
heels initially but she can't the other
thing i want to point
so again that that story plot line is
just
[ __ ] brutally bad okay
fine
there is a scene with for no reason
for no reason at all they just shoehorn
this scene and you guys are going to
when i watched it i was just like i was
in awe
going like wow there are not they are
not trying
so
that's the marie's right she goes i wish
to be gal gadot and i turned into a
cheetah
[ __ ] exactly what the [ __ ]
she by the way cgi worse than [ __ ]
cats
look this is her when she finally turns
into a cheetah that's
there it is so you can see the [ __ ]
the really great graphics look at that
oh wow their shoes is a cheetah so
anyway
um so with that there's that okay
the other thing i'm trying to understand
wonder woman empowered woman and all
this stuff
when wonder woman turns into when diana
prince is in her wonder woman outfit or
whatever
she's wearing like heels like you know
like
she's wearing heels and i'm like that is
not
conducive for crime fighting you would
be wearing flats now i know why they do
it they do it to make her look more
imposing
all right i get why they do it all right
couple other things in the movies that i
wanted to point out that i thought was
just [ __ ] so bad
so there was a scene
there was a scene when chris pine's
character
who is a a pilot okay
who is a pilot um
him and wonder woman steal a jet
now keep in mind couple things here
chris pine's character in the first
movie
was a world war one pilot so
you know what kind of planes he flew all
right
he was able to fly a modern 1980
modern for him 1984 fighter jet that
uses computer avionics and stuff
whatever fine fine fine it's a comic
book movie
fine but then they're flying
and then of course the genius hero
he you know he's for world war one
probably oh they're not gonna be able to
find me the way i fly and then she
remembers while they're already taking
off
oh that's right they have a thing called
radar now
again could have told them that earlier
but whatever [ __ ] it didn't
they get on the plane and they're like
oh no how they're going to find us
and then she just puts her hands
together right and she goes oh
by the way two minutes to it not even 30
seconds to explain a humongous plot
point that they did in this
oh my father hid the island uh femascara
by making it invisible that i've been
working on doing it and i made a coffee
cup invisible ones
and then she just puts her hands
together and she just has this new power
by the way
that she's never had in any comic book
in any movie in the linda carter tv show
it doesn't [ __ ] matter any [ __ ]
wonder woman
and she uses the power and she was able
to turn the jet invisible that wonder
woman did fly an invisible jet in the
super friends and all that stuff
but the jet was just an invisible jet
she turned the jet invisible
like she just had this power that came
out of nowhere
and she turned the jet invisible
i again two and a half hour movie
they didn't spend any time building up
to any of these new powers also
whenever you make a [ __ ] wish on the
[ __ ]
wishing stone or whatever um
whenever you make a wish on the wishing
stone
it grants your wish but it takes
something from you right like that's the
i don't know that that's that's the
[ __ ]
thing okay so what it takes from her
is you would think it takes her power
right
but it doesn't really take her power it
weakens her like her powers throughout
the whole movie
are very very inconsistent right they're
very very
inconsistent
where powers oppose supposedly go away a
little bit but not completely like she
could still run
super fast and she could still like push
cars and stuff
but now bullets hurt her and i guess
before bullets didn't hurt her
by the way something else i got to bring
up the cgi and have you seen this movie
please
back me up on this the cgi
in this is like cw level
cgi smallville level cgi like
the cgi looked [ __ ] terrible it's
like they did the cgi in 1984.
so again just
[ __ ] one of the worst things i've
seen there's more i'm not
done i watch this and if you're not
gonna watch it you at least need to
suffer a little bit with me
this is pedro pascal's max lord the
donald trump of the story
okay
the donald trump of the story
he's the evil businessman he's the bad
guy
that's him holding the wishing stone
which looks like a [ __ ] vibrator
or dildo at least
his storyline is all over the place he's
like some business guy
who's you know was a ponzi scheme and he
wishes
and that he uh
okay so so here's the thing again
two and a half hour movie they don't
really explain any of that
but
what his wish is it just in case you're
wondering like oh
maybe you're just [ __ ] oh you're just
saying that they're trying to make it be
like trump it's not like
oh wait what's this this is an actual
scene from the
movie all right
presidential shield standing in front of
it and everything so anyway
he wishes that he was the wishing stone
which i guess you could do that i guess
the wishing stone
in the [ __ ] thousands of thousands of
years that this wishing stone's been
around and all these people have used it
no one's ever thought why don't i just
become the wishing stone
apparently genies have stricter rules
than this [ __ ] wishing stone so he
became the wishing stone so
he could grant wishes as long as he's
touching people
he could grant wishes okay yeah i swear
to god
so he gets it to the white house and i
guess it's supposed to be reagan right
and he tells reagan um well what do you
wish for
you know and this is during the cold war
and reagan because of course it's just
it's just always
evil super [ __ ] villain [ __ ]
reagan wishes for not world peace
not to end communism not for anything
what do you think reagan wished for
because mind you a woman wrote this
you have to keep this in mind a woman
wrote and directed this
what do you think reagan wished for if
you know ronald reagan
what do you think he wished for he
didn't wish for infinite wishes
what do you think reagan wished for max
lord
no i'm just i'm white i'm gonna say what
do you think
not jelly jelly beans would have been
funny that's right
more nukes reagan wished for
more nukes that was his wish he could
have
anything that he wanted in the world he
could have
ended the cold war with one wish he
could have ended it
he could have ended it and he wished for
more nukes and at one point in the movie
stupid wonder woman
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] wonder woman stops a
heister or
whatever stops a heist or whatever
and she goes she breaks the guns and
then just
basically should have just looked at the
camera and winked while she said it was
like
i hate guns you're
literally [ __ ] [ __ ] and raping
a a world war one guy who all he did was
use guns
for whatever reason in the movie there's
a line when they're in the invisible jet
or whatever
and she wishes
that she doesn't wish you know she uh
oh by the way when you make these wishes
i'm sorry i forgot to tell you this part
of the movie
when you make these wishes you could
renounce them at any point
you could you could just renounce the
wishes at any point you want you could
just
renounce the wishes and say oh i don't
want that wish i [ __ ] up so again
nothing like a genie so she renounced
the wishes
chris pine dies again or disappears
again whatever
and then wonder woman learns like
[ __ ] like when the last like
10 minutes of the movie that she could
fly which would have been helpful
throughout the other part of the movie
but whatever
but before she's flying she's using her
her [ __ ] lasso and i swear to god
this is not a joke
and if you've watched this movie you'll
know what i'm talking about
she's using the lasso like spider-man
like she's whipping it on buildings and
swinging
like spiderman i swear to god like
spiderman
so she's whipping it up buildings and
just swinging
with her lasso right and then she at one
point like she looks she
she lassos a [ __ ] plane which by the
way would [ __ ] it up or whatever
she gets up in the sky and at one point
while she's lassoing things that this is
not a joke
again a woman wrote this she
lassos a cloud and is able to pull
herself
up from a cloud now i don't know if
you'd know this about clouds
okay because i mean i guess not
everyone's a meteorologist
like i am i guess but
you cannot pull yourself up from
water vapor or a cloud you can't
it's a [ __ ] cloud
but if you think her using the cloud
to put [ __ ] i swear to god this is
real
to pull herself up if you think that's
bad if you think that's bad
well have i got news for you
she lasso's a lightning bolt
and here's a picture of it if you don't
[ __ ] believe me that's fine
this is the picture of it
she lassos a god damn
lightning bolt and she
pulls herself
on a lightning bolt
oh my [ __ ] life on my life there's
the picture of it i'm not
i'm [ __ ] not lying
there is no consistency
beef true sick it's [ __ ] sick
this it was it [ __ ] oh my god
but we're not done no no we're not done
with the terrible craziness of this
movie
oh no we're not even close to dud okay
um [ __ ] i'm sorry it's just so much
happens
so after she lassoes herself to that she
goes back to
donald trump excuse me max lord and
you know he has all the wishing powers
whatever
so check out this plot point so
the wishing powers only work
the wishing powers
only work
if he's physically touching someone so
he has to be touching them
for for max lord who is now the wishing
stone keep up
who is now the wishing zone it only
works when he's touching people
well guess what when he goes to
president reagan's office he tells him
is there a way i could talk to everybody
on the planet
and reagan's like and check this out two
and a half hour movie this is a one
second explanation well
30 second explanation we have so
reagan's like
well we have something in the star wars
system
that lets us take over any ele this 1984
now
any electronic device not just tvs
any electronic device in the world
it could take over any electronic device
in the [ __ ] world
and broadcast their message doesn't make
any sense
especially in 1984 you wouldn't be able
to do that and they explained it away
with it's part of the star wars system
you know the system that reagan had the
anti-nuke system
and when explaining it reagan goes yeah
so these particles
literally go down you know we get these
these particles that literally go down
into any electronics
and then max lord goes wait a second are
you saying that these particles
are literally touching people
and reagan's like yeah bro i mean
obviously i'm just
paraphrasing yeah bro these little these
particles are like literally touching
people
max lord's like very cool i would take
over the world china
so that's basically in a nutshell what
happens
so these particles on this made up thing
that so
so [ __ ] he goes into this tv studio
that the president has in the cheyenne
mountains i believe
okay to the studio and he starts
broadcasting and asking everybody oh
make your wish what's your wish
and like [ __ ] this irish guy they
said they go all over the world and this
irish guy is like wishing like
oh you know you're you know i wish you
would die to the shop owner because
they're having an argument she goes
i wish they would round up people like
you of course it's an irish guy that
would never have the balls to do that to
any other
nationality so the cops were just
rounding up irish people in the uk just
rounding them up
at one point this woman wishes she was
famous and all of a sudden people start
taking pictures of her
and there's all these wishes there's all
these all these wishes all these all
this so
obviously the world starts going into
chaos now
reagan wished for more nukes so more
nukes pop up on the grid
russia sees it and russia's about to
launch more nukes
to the us because they say oh man you
have more nukes that's an act of
aggression
so of course because women don't know
how to write except being [ __ ]
childish
don't know how to write except for being
childish
the main villain is in max lord it's
nuclear war
okay so the nukes are gonna go off all
over the world so remember
are you keeping up are you are you
paying attention to what's happening in
this story i'm
i hope you're paying attention
yes billy nunez is right not only did
russia launch nukes they launched nukes
from
downtown moscow moscow so they
say show moscow and you see nukes just
popping first off they don't store their
nukes in downtown moscow
moscow they don't we don't store our
nukes in new york city
okay two and a half hours so
the only way for her to
stop it is she has to make the entire
world
renounce their wishes because the world
is going into chaos because everyone's
getting what they wish for
so max lord is standing there he's
talking to the world and there he's
listening to all their wishes or
whatever
and then the lasso
this one the one that lets you ride
lightning bolts okay
the one lets you ride lightning bolts
she lassos his foot
and apparently the magic lasso there's a
new power that you find out in the last
two minutes of the movie
can also if you've tied to somebody you
could speak through somebody
so she's talking she having a little
monologue and like telling people they
everyone in the world that they have to
renounce their wishes right
and guess what
every single person on the planet who
got what everything they wish for
every single one of them
renounce their wishes they all renounce
their wishes from evil maxwell lord they
all renounce their wishes
because of lightning writing lady okay
and then on top of all that oh by the
way i meant
i forgot to mention she does have a
fight with cheetah with kristin wig and
it's one of the worst fight scenes i've
ever seen
right it's just terrible fight scene
apparently wonder woman also had this
armor like this gold armor
for whatever reason um that
for i don't know why i mean they kind of
like it's another thing that they kind
of just mention in the
in the movie she has like this gold
armor
and she's fighting cheetah
kristen wigg's character with this gold
armor that has wings
by the way at this point in the movie
the wings are worthless
because she's already learned how to fly
without the wings but whatever
now kristen wiig renounces her [ __ ]
wish
and then she's fine there's no
repercussion she turns human and she's
fine
all the people in the world renounce
their their wishes and
and everything is [ __ ] back to normal
whatever
maxwell maxwell lord who has a kid in
this movie
he's a single dad who has a kid in this
movie
he also renounces his wishes because he
loves his son
and there's a scene where the last five
minutes of the movie where you have a
[ __ ] flashback to maxwell lord as a
kid and the reason that he was so
mean and one wanted to make these wishes
was because his
dad used to beat his mom i don't know
his dad used to beat his mom maxwell
lord also
never gets arrested he never gets in
trouble so
both of the main villains kristen wiig
cheetah maxwell lord
pedro pascal they don't even get
arrested
they just everything is fine and they
move on now
to make things even worse if you watch a
justice league movie if you watch the
batman vs superman movie
wonder woman has a line where she says
i've stayed out of human affairs for
over a hundred years because of
all of these terrible things that they
did except for the fact that she didn't
because in the [ __ ] 80s she was
literally fighting crime
in a goddamn mall so she's fighting
crime in a mall
[ __ ] beating up did the worst
henchmen but beating up all these
[ __ ] henchmen in a mall right
and on top of all that in the batman vs
superman and justice league movie her
name is diana prince
her name in this is also diana prince
she's widely publicized people know
people have seen diana prince she's a
big scientist because women have to be
scientists in movies because of
some sort of insecurity that women
directors have that they have to just
[ __ ] live vicariously with them
whatever i honestly don't even care
about that
she's still going by the same indiana
prince and nobody
in like 50 years has asked hey wait a
second
why the [ __ ] is diana prince not aging
why doesn't she age why is she [ __ ]
because they don't know that she's
wonder woman
remember keep in mind they think diana
prince is a separate person from wonder
woman
they don't even know so
it is one of the
worst things i have
ever seen ever
um but again
i urge
you to watch it
i urge you to watch the movie
because number one i don't want to
suffer alone
number two the
best thing that happened to this wonder
woman movie
the the very best thing that happened
to the the the best thing that happened
to this [ __ ] wonder woman movie
okay was
covet it's the best thing that could
have possibly happened
why because this movie
was going to [ __ ]
bomb if it was just out of theater it
was going
to [ __ ] bomb
but now now they don't have to worry
about it bombing
because it came out on hbo max and hbo
max
they don't have to release their numbers
so it'll just be
a commercial success
because ever because and then they'll
just use the covet
as the reason
so
that was uh my review
of the wonder woman movie
i'm sorry that i it's jesus christ i
went on for a while but i i i gotta
understand
i was screaming at the screen going what
is this this is [ __ ] terrible
what the actual [ __ ] is this [ __ ]